[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien schönen guten Abend
zusammen Christian das war ja eine super
Bilanz oder ist eine superbilanz der
deutschen Teams in der Champions schon
drei in der Ko-Runde guten Abend und
hier sind unsere Themen an diesem
Mittwoch
Milliarden gegen die Krise bunte und
Länder einigen sich auf die
gaspreisbremse und auf ein 49
euro-ticket
sprühen kleben blockieren die
klimaproteste der Aktivisten von der
letzten Generation stoßen zunehmend auf
Kritik
und Sieg in Lissabon nach München und
Dortmund zieht auch Frankfurt ins
Achtelfinale der Champions League ein
[Musik]
wochenlang haben sich bunt und Länder
über milliardenschwere Entlastungen
gestritten heute ging dann alles
ziemlich schnell vor gut einer
Dreiviertelstunde haben sie ihre
Beratungen beendet und eine
weitreichende Einigung erzielt
verständigt haben sich bunt und Länder
auf die Finanzierung des 49 euro-tickets
bei der Unterbringung von geflüchteten
will der Bund die Länder mit weiteren
Milliarden unterstützen beschlossen auch
die gaspreisbremse aus Berlin berichtet
Klaus Brodbeck
drei Stunden haben sie gerungen die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder und der
Bundeskanzler der Druck sich heute zu
einigen riesig am Ende aber ging es
überraschend schnell selbst für die
Beteiligten
das ist aus meiner Sicht und ich glaube
auch aus unserer gemeinsam Sicht ein
sehr sehr gutes Zeichen hat auch etwas
damit zu tun dass wir die heutige
Minister Zusammenkunft der
Regierungschefin Regierungschefs der
Länder mit mir sehr sehr sorgfältig
vorbereitet haben ich bin sehr froh
darüber dass wir in weiten Bereichen
Einigkeit erzielen konnten ich bin sehr
sicher das ist für Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wichtig ist das Gefühl zu haben
dass die unterschiedlichen staatlichen
Ebenen gut zusammenarbeiten dass sie
sich nicht in erster Linie streiten und
auseinandersetzen sondern
zusammenarbeiten und insbesondere auch
die Sorgen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
den Blick nehmen heute gibt es deutlich
mehr Klarheit bei der konkreten
Ausgestaltung der energiepreisbremse bei
der fairen Lastenverteilung für das
Entlastungspaket das Ergebnis ist wie es
auch nicht anders zu erwarten war
natürlich ein Kompromiss der Gaspreis
wird auf 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
gedeckelt der Strompreis auf
sind auch die Fernwärme soll gedeckelt
werden das sind heute die vielleicht
wichtigsten Punkte diese drei
entlastungsbremsen Gas
Fernwärme und Strom kommen jetzt für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für die
verbrauchen Verbraucher für die
Mieterinnen und Mieter für diejenigen
die Haus haben aber natürlich auch für
die Unternehmen jeweils entsprechend
abgestuft es ist gut dass wir dafür
jetzt den Rahmen gesteckt haben Minuten
zuvor feierte sich schon der
Verkehrsminister für ein bundesweites
Ticket im Nahverkehr mit dem heutigen
Beschluss ist der Weg frei für die
größte Tarifreform im öffentlichen
Nahverkehr in Deutschland Deutschland
bekommt ein neues Ticket nie war es
einfacher Bus und Bahn zu benutzen als
mit diesem neuen deutschlandticket dass
wir nun so schnell wie möglich einführen
wollen normalerweise gilt solch ein
Auftritt als Afro den das Kanzleramt
kaum vergessen dürfte heute aber machten
alle Zugeständnisse und allen Taten sie
weh so gesehen wohl ein guter Kompromiss
ordnen wir das Nummer eingehen nach
Berlin zu shakunta labernergy wie ist
denn das zu bewerten was bunt und Länder
da vor einer guten Dreiviertelstunde
vorgelegt haben man hat hier vor und
jetzt auch nach dieser Sitzung sehr
deutlich gespürt das ist Bund und
Ländern vor allem darum ging auch
Vertrauen in der Krisenpolitik
herzustellen und den Menschen ein Stück
weit Sicherheit zu geben nach
monatelangen Streitereien da sind beide
Seiten über ihre Schatten gesprungen der
Bund musste mehr Geld in den Topf
sozusagen in den Ring werfen als er das
ursprünglich vorgehabt hat die Länder
haben sich nicht mit allen Forderungen
durchgesetzt vor allem zwei größere
Punkte sind verschoben worden zum einen
der die Härtefallregelungen da sollen
sich jetzt noch einmal die
Wirtschaftsminister von Bund und Ländern
drüberbeugen und auch die sogenannte
winterlücke also die Frage wird es im
Januar nochmal Entlastungen bei den
Energiepreisen geben wird der Bund da
noch nachlegen da gibt es wohl hören wir
aus länderkreisen die Zusage aus dem
Bundeskanzleramt das Ganze bis zum 18.11
noch einmal zu beraten also keine
Einigung in allen Punkten aber trotzdem
haben sich heute doch alle noch einmal
zusammengerauft um deutlich zu machen
man springt hier über seinen Schatten
zugunsten von Entlastungen damit es
jetzt endlich mal wenigstens
schrittweise vorangeht dann danke für
die Bewertung nach Berlin Chuck und der
la benedici Inflation Energiekrise
belastend zwar die Wirtschaft trotzdem
ist die Zahl der Arbeitslosen im
oktober-saisonbedingt zurückgegangen
laut Bundesagentur für Arbeit waren zwei
Millionen 442.000 Menschen ohne Job
43.000 weniger als im September die
Quote sinkt um 0,1 Punkte auf 5,3
Prozent im Vergleich zum Vorjahresmonat
sind damit 65.000 Menschen mehr
arbeitslos trotz aller Krisen zeigt sich
der Arbeitsmarkt also bisher robust
allerdings seien die Folgen
wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheiten sichtbar
sagt die Chefin der Arbeitsagentur
Andrea Nahles und die Unternehmen selbst
die blicken mit großer Sorge auf das
nächste Jahr der deutsche Industrie und
handelskammertag befürchtet dass das
Schlimmste noch kommt Dominik Müller
Russell berichtet
sie gießen Stahl für Kräne und Schiffe
Züge und Busse doch wie lange das
Geschäft noch so läuft wie bislang
wissen sie nicht beim
stahlgussunternehmen Trier in Bielefeld
ihren Kunden müssen sie sagen dass ihre
Produkte nächstes Jahr um rund 40%
teurer werden vor allem wegen der
deutlich gestiegenen Energiekosten
unsere Angst ist dass im nächsten Jahr
Aufträge dann über kurz oder langfristig
eventuell ins Ausland gehen Richtung
Asien so dass also unsere Kunden sich
dann neue bezugsfällen suchen würden
wenn die Preise in Deutschland nicht
mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind die Lage ist
zur düster wie nie sagt der Industrie-
und handelskammertag nach einer Umfrage
unter mir als 20.000 deutschen Betrieben
und nicht nur Kunden auch viele
Unternehmen selbst prüfen zur Zeit
günstigere Alternativen eine Verlagerung
auch an ausländische Standorte spielt
dabei eine Rolle
hierzulande ist dann die Frage wie sich
das auf den Arbeitsmarkt auswirkt nicht
gut hat auch die Stiftung
Familienunternehmen unter rund 1000
ihrer Mitglieder ermitteln lassen
darunter viele Mittelständler düsterer
Aussichten wir sehen jetzt dass die
Auftragseingänge nachlassen und die
Unternehmen müssen natürlich nachziehen
also wir haben gerade eine Umfrage
gemacht über das info-institut und
danach denken etwa 25% der Unternehmen
einen Arbeitsplatzabbau 300 Mitarbeiter
beschäftigt die Stahlgießerei Trier die
Hoffnung hier dass der Staat schnell und
kräftig unterstützt bei den
Energiepreisen sonst sehen sie schwarz
zu Corona und dem Eingeständnis eines
Fehlers in den ersten corona-wellen
Kitas zu schließen war medizinisch nicht
angemessen und unnötig so stets im
Abschlussbericht der corona-kita-studie
die Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach und
Familienministerin Paus heute
vorstellten in der Pandemie hätten
Kinder oft weniger am Virus gelitten
erklärte Pause als an den Maßnahmen
gegen das Virus
die Ukraine kann jetzt doch wieder
Getreide exportieren russland hat das
Abkommen dazu unerwartet wieder in Kraft
gesetzt die Schiffe mit weizenmaßen und
anderen Agrarprodukten sollen demnach
weiter über einen sicheren Korridor im
Schwarzen Meer fahren Moskau gab an
schriftliche Sicherheitsgarantien von
Kiew erhalten zu haben dass der
seekorridor nicht für Kampfhandlungen
genutzt werde der Korn Deal ist wichtig
für den Kampf gegen den Hunger in der
Welt
jetzt nach Israel er hat es tatsächlich
geschafft nach Auszählung fast aller
Stimmen geht Benjamin netanjau mit
seinem rechtskonservativen liquidblock
als stärkste Kraft hervor Bibi so wird
er ja genannt könnte also zum dritten
Mal israelischer Ministerpräsident
werden allerdings nur mit Hilfe einer
rechtsextremen Partei über das Baby
Comeback und den Rechtsruck berichtet
Michael Beverungen
nichts konnte seine Rückkehr zur Macht
verhindern nicht die Skandale nicht die
Prozesse deretwegen er vor Gericht steht
und nicht der Pakt mit dubiosen
politischen Partnern sein Lager aus
rechtskonservativen
Ultraorthodoxen und teils rassistischen
Ultranationalisten hat eine klare
Mehrheit und seine Anhänger vom Liquid
huldigen ihm Bibi König von Israel
[Applaus]
sachino heute haben wir ein großes
Vertrauensvotum erhalten unser Weg der
Weg des leecode hat sich durchgesetzt
dieser Weg beinhaltete ihnho-fähig zu
machen die Tamar Benk ein mehrfach
verurteilter Volksverhetzer und
Terrorismus Unterstützer der die Macht
der Gerichte einschränken und unliebsame
Araber deportieren will seine religiösen
Zionisten sind nun drittstärkste Kraft
Populist es handelt sich um eine
populistische Kraft die einfache Rezepte
für Fragen der persönlichen Sicherheit
der Israelis anbietet die wollten diesem
scheinbar authentischen Führer eine
Chance geben
darüber ist die Wählerschaft aber
gespalten wie eh und je unternehmerische
ich bin überglücklich wir haben unsere
Sicherheit zurück keine Angst auf der
Straße zu laufen keine Angst vor Arabern
ich habe Sorge dass unsere Freiheit
beschränkt wird die zwischen Männern und
Frauen Juden und Arabern religiösen und
säkularen
israel steht nun vor einer Zeitenwende
noch nie waren die extremen Kräfte in
einer Regierung so stark ob die sich
beherrschen lassen oder mehr Konflikte
verursachen als zu lösen das ist die
große Zukunftsfrage für Israel
andere Wahl anderes Land in Dänemark hat
das Linksbündnis von Ministerpräsidentin
Fredriksen die Parlamentswahlen zwar
äußerst knapp gewonnen trotzdem will die
Sozialdemokratin mit dieser hauchdünnen
Mehrheit nicht weiter regieren sie
reichte ihren Rücktritt ein es sei
deutlich dass die Regierungen der
jetzigen Form nicht weitermachen können
sagte Fredericksen sie wolle nun
lagerübergreifend neue Mehrheiten suchen
[Applaus]
kommenden Dienstag hat der Wähler dann
in den USA das Wort bei den mitturms den
Zwischenwahlen da geht es auch um die
Frage gewinnen die Republikaner
vielleicht sogar Ex-Präsident Trump
wieder an Einfluss vor allem im Senat
und im Repräsentantenhaus in beiden kann
man haben die Demokraten die Mehrheit
und das könnte sich ändern wenn die 50
Bundesstaaten ihre Abgeordneten wählen
tief gespalten ist etwa Florida hier
greift nun auch der in Umfragen
angeschlagene demokratische Präsident
beiden in den Wahlkampf ein Claudia
Bates aus den USA
Joe Biden weiß dass seine gesamte
politische Agenda auf dem Spiel steht
wenn die Demokraten ihre Mehrheit im
Parlament verlieren ist es das Ende
jedes größeren Vorhabens zu spät aber
hat er erkannt dass der eigene
Geldbeutel den Menschen näher ist als
Themen wie Abtreibung oder Demokratie
deswegen preist er seine
wirtschaftspolitische Bilanz
zehn Millionen neue Arbeitsplätze noch
keine Regierung hat das geschafft die
Arbeitslosigkeit ist von 6,5 auf 3,5%
gesunken der niedrigste Stand in 50
Jahren
doch hohe Preise tun vielen Menschen weh
und das nützt den Republikanern Floridas
Gouverneur ronde Säntis den beiden einen
Wiedergänger Donald Trumps nennt
wenn ihr mehr für Lebensmittel zahlt
bedankt euch bei Joe Biden wenn ihr mehr
bezahlt für Rechnungen und alles andere
dann bedankt Euch bei den Demokraten
denn sie haben das in die USA gebracht
doch für das Land geht es um viel mehr
der frühere Präsident Trump hat die
Mehrheit der republikanischen Wähler
weiterhin im Griff wie einen Kult gegen
ihn geht nichts im ganzen Land
kandidieren hunderte Politiker die seine
wahllüge unterstützen und bereit sind so
die Demokratie zu untergraben
nicht mehr die republikanische Partei
eurer Väter das ist jetzt was ganz
anderes sie wollen euch eure Stimme
nehmen das ist wirklich tot Ernst die
Demokratie steht auf dem Stimmzettel
dieses Jahr
traditionell aber ist die zwischenwahl
eine Abrechnung mit der regierenden
Partei
und zu den Zwischenwahlen in den USA
heute Abend die auslandsjournal Doku
unseres USA Korrespondent Belma teven
Trumps langer Schatten um viertel nach
zehn gleich nach dem heute journal
im Kampf gegen Corona setzte China von
Anfang an auf eine Null
toleranz-strategie gibt's Infektionen
dann werden ganze Städte Regionen sofort
abgeriegelt und das geschieht jetzt auch
nach einem corona-ausbruch in einem
smartphone-werk in Zentral China das für
die ganze Welt produziert Miriam Steimer
diese Menschen fliehen aus der größten
iPhone Fabrik der Welt die einzelnen
Videos sind schwer zu verifizieren in
chinesischen Netzwerken hat die Zensur
sie alle gelöscht
gestern abend um 10 bin ich losgelaufen
jetzt ist es 12 Uhr mittags und wir sind
immer noch unterwegs
sie wollen nach Hause denn auf dem
Firmengelände soll es so aussehen es gab
einen corona-ausbruch positive Fälle
wurden in den werksunterkünften isoliert
die Produktion lief weiter doch die
Verantwortlichen verloren wohl die
Kontrolle augenzeugen berichten dass es
nicht genug zu essen gab Kranke nicht
versorgt wurden
ich bin in Quarantäne ich habe 39,3
Fieber niemand kümmert sich um mich
[Musik]
viele fliehen auch aus Angst vor dem
Virus jetzt spricht die
Gesundheitsbehörde des Bezirks zum
ersten Mal davon das Corona nicht so
schlimm sei und behandelt werden können
bis zu 300.000 Menschen produzieren hier
in der Provinz etwa die Hälfte aller
iPhones weltweit das trifft das wichtige
Vorweihnachtsgeschäft 55 Euro
tagesprämie soll die Leute jetzt
überzeugen zu bleiben wer keinen Filter
hat kriegt doch mal 700 Euro extra
heute hat die Stadt das ganze
Industriegebiet abgeriegelt viele sind
froh es vorher rausgeschafft zu haben
egal wie
krasses Bild wir wechseln den Kontinent
in Äthiopien gibt es Hoffnung auf
Frieden nach zwei Jahren Krieg haben die
äthiopische Regierung und die
volksbefreiungsfront von T3 einen
sofortigen Waffenstillstand vereinbart
vermittelt durch die Afrikanische Union
bei dem Konflikt sollen mehr als eine
halbe Million Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sein
die klimaaktivisten wollen
Aufmerksamkeit ihrer Aktionen sind
genauso spektakulär wie umstritten sie
nennen sich die letzte Generation und
sie beschmieren wertvolle Gemälde sie
besprühen Fassaden so wie heute die von
Parteizentralen in Berlin und sie kleben
sich auf Straßenfest und behindern so
den Verkehr in Berlin kam möglicherweise
deswegen ein Rettungsfahrzeug nicht
rechtzeitig zu einem Unfallopfer was
darf Protest Carsten Behrendt berichtet
auch heute wieder Blockade fürs Klima
auf Berlins Straßen die Kritik daran
wird lauter nachdem am Montag ein
Spezialfahrzeug der Feuerwehr auf dem
Weg zu einem schweren Fahrradunfall
ausgebremst wurde wegen Klimaschützern
auf der Stadtautobahn der Fall wird nun
juristisch geprüft der Justizminister
weist auf mögliche Folgen für die
Aktivisten hin bis zur Freiheitsstrafen
wer sogar Leben und Leib anderer
Menschen gefährdet überschreitet die
Grenzen des Akzeptablen Protests wäre so
etwas tut tut auch seinem Anliegen einen
Bärendienst an in dem Fall dem
Klimaschutz Berlins Justiz hat bislang
729 Strafverfahren eingeleitet meist
wegen Nötigung und Eingriffs in den
Straßenverkehr die ersten Urteile
Strafbefehle mit Geldstrafen die
Aktivisten Bedauern heute mögliche
Auswirkungen auf Rettungsmaßnahmen aber
sie wollen sich nicht von drohenden
Strafen stoppen lassen es ist im Moment
gerade diese Form des Protestes das
effektivste Mittel was uns am Ende noch
übrig bleibt weil keine anderen
Protestformen mehr ausreichen und wir
haben nicht mehr viel Zeit wir rasen auf
eine Klimakatastrophe zu wir sind jetzt
schon mittendrin und wir müssen jetzt
handeln
wie radikal darf klimaprotest sein das
ist auch unter Beobachtern umstritten es
besteht natürlich durchaus die Gefahr
dass die Bevölkerung jetzt die Bewegung
als Ganzes kritisches sieht andererseits
es wird ja trotzdem Aufmerksamkeit für
das Thema generiert und das kann zum
Beispiel Fridays for future natürlich
auch wieder helfen dadurch das Thema
präsenter ist aber sie als der moderate
Teil der Bewegung gesehen werden fest
steht die umstrittenen Proteste und
deren Folgen heizen das Diskussionsklima
immer weiter auf
sehr viel positiver Aufmerksamkeit hat
gestern Eintracht Frankfurt erfahren ich
habe mir das Spiel gestern angeguckt das
war packen Millionen andere auch und für
die Mannschaft muss es ja auch glaube
ich gewesen sein man kriegt gleich
wieder Gänsehaut nur beim Zuschauen das
reicht schon mal wieder so eine Partie
für die Geschichtsbücher der Eintracht
nach Rückstand den notwendigen Sieg bei
Sporting Lissabon erkennt zum ersten Mal
im Achtelfinale der Königsklasse auch
dank der Einwechslung eines Spielers
Sebastian Rode mit nur einer gespielten
Halbzeit ganz offiziell man of the match
seine Eintracht noch ohne ihren zunächst
geschonten Kapitän als Lissabon durch
Gomez mit 1:0 in Führung geht Frankfurt
zur pausegruppen letzter und völlig raus
aus Europa dann aber kommt Rohde und mit
ihm Struktur und Stabilität als es dann
einen Handelfmeter gibt und kamada
unfassbar entspannt antritt ist der eins
zu eins Ausgleich geschafft aber noch
viel Frankfurt ein Siegtreffer um in der
Champions League zu überwintern den
erzielt dann unwiderstehlich Eintracht
Shooting Star Colo moani danach noch
etwas zittern und nach Abpfiff pure
Freude geiles Gefühl und man hat gesehen
die die Freude nach dem Spiel mit den
Fans zusammen die Europareise geht
weiter der debütantentanz ist noch nicht
beendet
auch bei Leverkusen bleibt auf
europäischer Bühne allerdings in der
Europa League das Team von chabi Alonso
spielte zwar nur 0:0 gegen den FC Brücke
profitiert aber vom Sieg des FC Porto
gegen Atletico Madrid und verbesserte
sich auf den dritten Tabellenplatz
und als Vierter deutscher Verein hat RB
Leipzig die Chance ins Achtelfinale
einzuziehen trifft gerade auf Schachtjor
Donezk ein Punkt würde reichen alles zum
Vorrundenabschluss von 23 Uhr an im
ZDF-Sportstudio UEFA Champions League
sowie online in der ZDF heute App
die Turnerinnen der USA haben auch ohne
sei man Balz erneut den Teamwettbewerb
bei einer Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen in
Liverpool sicherte sich die
amerikanische Frauenriege zum sechsten
Mal nacheinander den Titel ein Rekord
damit sind sie seit elf Jahren bei einer
WM unbesiegt Silber ging ein
Großbritannien Bronze an Kanada die
Deutschen die hatten das Finale verpasst
dann vielen Dank für das Sport Update
Kristin und wir haben noch die Zahlen
vom Mittwochslotto und die gehen so 9 15
16 17 21 48 und die Superzahl 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf lotto.zdf.de oder auf
der zdf-textseite 557
morgen bleibt der November noch mild zum
Wochenende wird es dann deutlich kälter
mehr Wetter gibt es gleich mit Katja
horneffer NRW Ministerpräsident wüst ab
21:45 Uhr im heute-journal Interview mit
Christian Sievers das war es von uns am
Mittwoch machen sie sich noch einen
entspannten Abend und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen wird noch mal ein
ruhiger Novembertag dann aber zieht
dieses Hoch ostwärts ab und Tiefs
übernehmen die wetterregie mit vielen
Wolken mit Regen in den Alpen auch mit
Schnee und mit viel Wind heute Nacht ist
es im Osten häufig klar und an der Donau
oder auch am Bodensee bildet sich bei
wenig Wind cernebit im Westen gibt es
dichtere Wolken bei Südwind und da
sinken die Temperaturen hier zum
Beispiel auf den Ostfriesischen Inseln
oder auch am Niederrhein auf 10 Grad
kälter wird es in den restlichen
Mittelgebirgen mit null Grad dort droht
also Bodenfrost und die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 12 Grad in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und 17 oder vielleicht
sogar 18 Grad am Rhein am Vormittag
zeigt sich hier im Osten noch häufig die
Sonne sind sind schon viele Wolken
unterwegs es dauert aber wohl bis in den
Nachmittag bis hier von Westen der Regen
einsetzt dazu wird der Wind recht
kräftig aus falschen Richtung und der
Würde Drehen am Freitag auf Nordwest und
damit wird es markant kälter die
Temperaturen liegen dann noch bei 6 bis
13 Grad das fällt am Freitag häufig
Regen am Samstag zieht der ostwärts ab
der Sonntag wird dann schon wieder recht
freundlich guten Abend